[Music]
Twitter pulley you could stay one age
forever what would it be easy 21 no way
I'd be 10 oh no time was the worst man I
say 30 it's like the height of
sophistication beautiful what about the
age where right now I'd like to stay
like this friends seriously what's wrong
with you okay fine the age we are right
now but we'll get all live in a house -
okay fine
but without run though yeah obviously
that goes without saying super funny
guys
the dude bros in the natural habitat
let's observe shall we hey Tom so what's
the plan tonight big plan hey it's top
secret oh I see a circle jerk hey hey
cow so what's the big secret I mean I
could tell you but then I'd have to kill
you okay buddy yeah creaking you guys
either got my sister but I love you Bob
tonight
bumped into coach Sanders today
did your 1600 meter time is really
improving while the train is paying off
nice work sweetheart did you tell them
Dolores Constantino quit the team why
she's pregnant what is he planning to do
now he's gonna drop out and keep it baby
I assume run is gonna be at Katie's
tonight yeah so so what are you guys
gonna do you know drink a lot of vodka
and meet guys online funny very funny
can I come
not a chance you said I could come next
time hey hey do you think I could hang
out you guys ah yeah not tonight
grasshopper sorry maybe maybe next time
oh I wear the shirt you gave me to
school got sent to the principal's
office well done man
yes hey hey
you know they have POV porn
yes ones from our house he doing he's
probably just looking for another bottle
sometimes I wish I could just leave no
why don't we just all leave this stupid
town together oh where do we go I have
friends in Paris we could totally stay
with them what friends you've never been
to Paris
my mom has friends there idiot dumb I
wish I'll just be stuck here forever in
this [ __ ] seriously no I think you
and Carl would make an adorable couple
it's Kyle and I don't like him but we
all know that you wish your little
secret sausagefest right now no but I do
know what their secret is oh yeah and do
tow so they're getting together tonight
at Tom's house in his garage to summon
Slender Man creepy who's Slenderman he's
he's the guy who makes all those kids
disappear why have I not heard of this
it's much longer conversation Slenderman
can manifest in a variety of forms
certain accounts speak of a notic power
that renders his victims helpless to
stop themselves from walking into
waiting arms while his origins and
motives are completely unknown
he preys upon innocent youth once you
see him you're his sum he takes some he
doesn't nobody knows why he takes who he
takes or why he leaves who he leaves but
the ones he leaves behind are messed up
forever all right here it is
how does summon Slenderman guys we so
have to do this we actually don't
actually if they're doing it we're doing
it oh this feels wrong this feels like
Russian malware a virus types come on
don't be such a wuss those who hear the
three bells toll accept his invitation
when you hear the first you must close
your eyes
keeping words unspoken if one wants to
hear you must listen closely for they
are soft and distant with eyes still
closed and mind wide open clear your
thoughts and await the second opening
your eyes only once you heard the third
are you serious this is Shh
what a stupid video can we do something
else let's watch a movie
young
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where is my daughter
people don't just disappear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]